It seemed that The Foundation was all but rid of
SCP-682 after an unlikely glitch in reality sent
the hard-to-destroy reptile deep into a limitless
interdimensional abyss known simply as The
Backrooms. This meant that the standard reality,
also known as The Frontrooms, was safe from one of
the most dangerous monsters in existence, but
that didn’t mean the anomaly was neutralized.
SCP-682 had been slowly but surely
making its way through every level of
The Backrooms and taking out its aggression
on any living thing that crossed its path.
Well, except for Jerry. There was something
about the entity which resembled blue
hyacinth macaw that had made it tolerable
to SCP-682, which was rare for the reptile,
as it infamously regarded most other lifeforms
as disgusting and worthy only to be destroyed.
Jerry had been frightened away by an encounter
with the archers of Level 10, and ever since
SCP-682 had been looking for the little guy.
This search eventually led the creature to
backtrack through the suburbs of Level 9 and
enter Level 11: the “presumably” infinite city.
This was the largest settlement that
SCP-682 had seen in The Backrooms,
and whether or not it found its avian companion,
it was eager to cause some havoc among the locals.
And speaking of the locals, what a sorry sight
they were. Countless Facelings were acting like
ordinary humans going about their day, strolling
down the sidewalks and entering buildings,
seemingly with no reason other than to humor
the themed environment. A few of the Facelings
were even walking Hounds on leashes, in
a grotesque pantomime of a dog walker.
682 was infuriated. Somehow, in its seemingly
infinite ways of causing the creature distress,
The Backrooms had managed to combine
the two things that annoyed it most:
the so-called “civilized” creatures of its
native reality and the equally disgusting
entities that dwelled within The Backrooms.
Unable to stand to look at this any longer,
SCP-682 went on a violent rampage, attacking
every entity in sight. Its previous objective
of seeking Jerry no longer mattered to it,
as the anomaly’s disgust for every part of
this alternate reality overwhelmed all of
its thoughts. If 682 found itself
starring in Pixar’s Inside Out,
all of the emotions in its mind
would be variations of disgust.
As the bodies started to pile up, SCP-682
began to sense something in the air waves
of this Level. It soon adapted a long-range
radio antenna in order to better pick up on the
frequency. The voice on the other was calm,
and sounded like a middle-aged human male.
“You’re listening to Radio Backrooms.” The
voice said. “If you’re just tuning in now,
welcome to Talkin’ With
Ralph. I’m your host, Ralph!”
There you are. SCP-682 said, triangulating
the radio signal with its internal senses.
This “Ralph” character was going to be next to
die. Well, he’d be next if nothing else with a
dumb look about it got in the way. And in The
Backrooms, the chances were high that a new
pathetic creature for SCP-682 to destroy
would be around every corner. Either way,
682 marked the new waypoint on its mental map
and started to zero in on Ralph’s location.
“Looks like we’ve got ourselves a brand
new entity in Level 11.” Ralph’s voice
echoed in SCP-682’s skull. “I’ll be giving away a
free time slot to whichever faction bags
the beast within the next twelve hours.”
SCP-682 realized almost immediately that it must
have been the new entity that Ralph was referring
to. It was familiar with the idea of factions
within The Backrooms because of its previous
encounters with the Major Explorer Group, but now
the situation threatened to get interesting. Maybe
there would be some factions here with actual
combat training on par with the mobile task
forces. Could these new factions pose a
challenge to such a powerful keter-class anomaly?
682 heard the buzzing of
tiny propellers overheard,
and saw a group of surveillance drones
flying towards it. With catlike agility,
it leaped into the air and swatted the drones
with its limbs and claws. The cheap hunks of
carbon fiber were shattered easily. Halfway
across the city, several members of The Drone
Surveillance Squad were throwing their
headsets on the ground in frustration.
With one faction having missed its chance,
the next was quick to arrive. Five cool
teens on bikes and skateboards rolled up
to the end of the street. They were all
dressed in 80s fashion, for some reason.
“Check it out! That’s one righteous
reptile!” said one of the teens.
“Gnarly!” said another.
682 cringed. Even with its limited
understanding of human culture,
it could tell that 80s nostalgia was
overplayed, and that the era of 90s
and 2000s nostalgia would soon arrive.
And what better way to hasten it than
getting these troubled teens off the street.
Just don’t ask where they went after that.
Another so-called faction down and SCP-682
was already feeling uncontested. So far
these humans were even less intimidating than
the entities. This was a bit mind-boggling to
SCP-682 considering that the Foundation was
made up of humans and they had managed to bag
several much scarier anomalies than anything
in The Backrooms. Naturally, SCP-682 included
itself among that number. The radio studio where
Talkin’ with Ralph was broadcasting from was
getting ever closer. Taking a slight detour, the
reptile tore straight through Level 11’s M.E.G.
base of operations. Once again, the explorers
within proved to be no match for the creature.
It emerged out the other side of the
building, back into the city streets,
and was immediately confronted with several
new explorers. These humans weren’t exactly
80s fashionable, opting instead for
tactical gear and long black cloaks.
They had a haunted look about them
and each carried a mighty spear.
“Sinner!” They shouted in unison.
“The eyes of Argos are upon you!”
SCP-682 pounced and made short work of them,
but paused warily when it noticed the presence
of a slightly taller humanoid that had been
standing behind the group. It was dressed
the same as the humans, but it had an aura
of mythic fury. The humanoid had no eyes,
but somehow, SCP-682 could feel itself
being watched, as if from all places at
once. It was unsettling for the creature, as
it felt like being back at the Foundation.
Contained in a vat of acid while a science lab
full of researchers watched and judged. Yes,
judged. That was the feeling.
And SCP-682 knew it all too well.
The humanoid stepped forward,
brandishing its spear.
What was it with this place
and spears? SCP-682 wondered.
The powerful entity it had fought on
Level 7 had also wielded a spear. Was
that weapon meant to be some indication
that this one was just as tough?
“I am all-seeing Argos, and I have seen that your
sins are innumerable!” said the humanoid entity.
Argos lunged forward, thrusting with its spear
towards 682. The reptile received the brunt
of the strike and was launched backward.
Without even giving 682 time to recover,
Argos thrust its spear through the
creature, pinning it to the concrete.
“Sinners must be punished!” Argos bellowed,
pushing the spear deeper into the reptile’s body.
SCP-682 struck back with a bite, but to its
surprise, Argos seemed to have an impossibly
high tolerance for pain and its wounds seemed to
be healing almost as soon as they opened. This
told 682 that close-range attacks wouldn’t get
this entity’s spear out of its back. It needed
to get the freaky humanoid out of spear range,
and then hit back with a reach weapon of its own.
Tapping once again into the radio frequencies,
682 levied a blast of concussive sonic energy from
its body. While this didn’t damage Argos, it did
achieve the intended effect of knocking the entity
a few feet back. SCP-682 used this chance to get
a bit of distance, and readied its next weapon:
its own reptilian tail, now-elongated and
equipped with a sharp blade at the end.
In terms of reach, SCP-682’s tail whip
outclassed Argos’ spear. The battle was
on now. 682 swung its powerful blade in an
attempt to cut through the enemy's weapon,
but it seemed that the spear had the same
regenerative abilities as its wielder.
“You’re not human.” SCP-682 taunted
Argos. “You’re even more disgusting!”
“You are a sinner!” Argos replied.
Regeneration was one of SCP-682’s strong
suits too, and the spear wounds that Argos
had given it had already recovered.
Using the bladed-whip of its tail,
SCP-682 kept Argos and his spear out of
close-quarters. It continued to slash the entity,
but the wounds were healing too quickly
to leave an impression. Argos was also
skilled enough with his spear that he began
to deflect the whip and advance towards 682.
It was time to try something crazy. So crazy it
just might work. Argos stopped in his tracks,
as suddenly SCP-682 was nowhere to be found.
The reptile had become effectively invisible,
and this was because it had adapted to counter
Argos’ “true vision.” Now encased in a ghostly
aura of sin-cloaking energy, SCP-682 maneuvered
around Argos and prepared to finish it off.
If you’re like me, then this won’t bring you down.
But it will hurt, Argos, and I will enjoy it.
Calling upon the memories of the
acid vats back at the Foundation,
SCP-682 secreted a powerful acid across
its entire body and leapt onto Argos’
back. The thing about spears is, while they are
ideal for engaging the opponent at a distance,
they were far less useful if that same opponent
was grappling your limbs. With his weapon rendered
unusable, Argos was now locked in a battle of
endurance with SCP-682 - it had generated the
most powerful acid it could generate, potent
enough to even cause a bit of damage to itself.
“It’s over, Argos.” SCP-682 chuckled. “You
may be good at fighting, but only one of
us has spent years being contained
within a caustic prison. You lose.”
SCP-682 held down Argos for as long as it took for
the acid to fully immobilize him. The entity had
struggled to break free, but 682 was able to
continually grow strong enough to tighten its
grip. With the boss of this level destroyed,
SCP-682 continued towards the radio tower.
“Uhh… umm…. Congratulations, you!”
Ralph said over the radio. “You win,
lizard man. How about you and
I have a nice, peaceful chat.”
Not having any of this,
SCP-682 beamed its own words into the
radio station along the same frequency.
“Tell me how to get to the next level,
and I’ll consider sparing you. But only
because you’re just that worthless.”
“I hear ya, lizard man!”
Ralph responded, nervously.
Ralph directed SCP-682 to a specific window
inside of one of the nearby skyscrapers.
When SCP-682 opened this window, it
was immediately transported into a
cramped white room with a table
that had a single chair nearby.
This was Level 12?
682 was most assuredly going back
for Ralph later. Yet another level
seemed specifically created to play
on the ennui of the human condition,
which was something that 682 still
had no frame of reference for.
Humans were afraid of the stupidest
things. SCP-682 thought to itself.
It waited in this white room for
what felt like several hours until
it was eventually no-clipped back into Level 11.
“RALPH!!!”
SCP-682 roared, loud enough to shatter the glass
windows on several buildings in the infinite city.
It charged out of the skyscraper and onto
the roof of a nearby apartment building,
which just so happened to be
another surface with no-clip
capabilities. 682 never got to hear a
response back from the talk radio host
before it fell several stories down into
another level of The Backrooms entirely.
Level 13: An apartment building
that, while not technically infinite,
was presumed to have a very high
number of floors. The hallways were
more cramped than the hotel on Level 5,
so SCP-682 shrunk itself a bit to avoid
getting stuck. It gritted its teeth
and prepared for the usual routine.
3…2…1…
A clump, a female moth, and a hound came slinking
down the hallway like a random encounter in a
JRPG. SCP-682 hated these Backrooms entities so
very much, and could barely fathom why they could
stand each other. It seemed that no matter
what level these hostile entities appeared,
the goon squad only ever attacked creatures
that weren’t native to The Backrooms.
Without further deliberation,
SCP-682 ran the Three Stooges over,
trampling them with its superior power.
It was more than done taking small fry
seriously and that included Curly, Larry, and Moe.
As it wandered through the halls, SCP-682 started
to hear the droning easy-listening music which
pervaded this entire level. It was the sort
of sound that humans used in elevators and
grocery stores, places where the dull mundanity
of life was meant to serve as a comfort. And yet,
it seemed to be the soundtrack of
The Backrooms latest hellish level.
In a way, SCP-682 started to feel
pity for the humans trapped here,
not because their suffering was a bad thing from
its perspective, but because of the fragility
of their finite psyches. If whatever force
that created The Backrooms did intend it to
be a realm that tormented humans, the humans
were definitely making it too easy. And if
humans themselves made this to contain other
humans, the implications were even sillier.
When the very structures that humans
built to shelter themselves from the
elements - apartment buildings, cities, towns
- were able to cause this much fear in them,
it was a sure sign that humanity was always doomed
to retreat screaming back into the wilderness
after centuries of learning nothing from its
collective delusion of civilization. Or at
least they would be doomed to that fate, if they
weren’t already doomed to be wiped out by SCP-682.
Just like every entity in The Backrooms.
682 wouldn’t rest until every last faceling,
clump, death moth, death rat, smiler, hound,
duller, burster, and any other ridiculous
entity that dared to crawl through these
wretched corridors was personally sent to its
end. It got so pumped up thinking about this
that it didn’t even notice itself no-clipping
again. Thousands of floors rushed by in the blink
of a moment until the reptile finally dropped
through the lobby of the apartment building.
A new level unlocked! Just like that!
SCP-682 regained its bearings on
a forest floor covered in vibrant
crimson grass. The trees had pitch-black bark,
almost blending in with the night itself. The
sky above was a glistening sea of bright stars.
This was level 14 - known to most explorers
as Paradise. This level had a strange power
which supposedly made the explorer happy and
feeling as though they belonged. However much
like the darkness within the suburbs, Level
14’s happiness-inducing atmosphere would
have the opposite effect on
the hard-to-destroy reptile.
It hated this forest even more than
any previous level of the backrooms
and wanted out immediately. From
experience, 682 knew that poking
around would eventually result in it
finding the entrance to the next level,
so it high-tailed its way through the trees.
It needed to find that exit desperately.
As it ran through the woods, 682 could
hear howling somewhere far in the distance,
and it didn’t sound like a pack
of wild animals. Disturbingly,
it sounded like a crowd of humans attempting
noises similar to wolves, but they were
committing so much to the performance that it
almost seemed like they truly believed they
were wolves. Whatever hippy-dippy nonsense
was going on here wasn’t SCP-682’s concern.
Right now, it was burning with so much contempt
for Level 14 that it could barely think straight.
Its feet crashed through a field of pale-white
bones, lying just beneath the grass, but it kept
on running. It collided with a tree, downing
it in a second, but it just kept running. The
howling ceased in the distance, and still, SCP-682
continued to run as fast and as far as it could.
Then, against all odds, the
creature's own mind began to
turn against it as the effect of
Level 14 continued to take hold.
You don’t belong anywhere.
You are a mistake of nature.
SCP-682 could recognize its own
voice echoing in its head and
for the first time, it was terrified of itself.
You are a thing that cannot ever be happy. This
paradise will never accept you.
Nowhere will ever accept you.
You are… disgusting.
SCP-682 froze in its tracks. There was
no exit from this place. The Backrooms
had won the sick game it was playing with the
reptile’s existence. It would be trapped here
forever in this inverted Paradise for humans: a
self-loathing immortal without any hope of escape.
It was so paralyzed by the immense disgust that
it felt for itself that it almost didn’t notice
a speck of blue among all the red: the
blue on the feathers of a hyacinth macaw.
“Jerry?” SCP-682 said aloud.
Don’t follow him. You are a monster. You
will never know companionship or love.
“Shut up, you disgusting creature!”
SCP-682 growled back at its own mind.
Shakily, it began to move its legs in
the direction of Jerry. The bird-like
entity was the only thing that still
felt real about Level 14. Everything
practically faded away into a churning
ocean of red and black. It took every
ounce of willpower that SCP-682 had,
but it kept moving towards Jerry.
You are the disgusting monster
to ever exist. The Foundation
should have destroyed you. The Backrooms will
destroy you. You don’t belong in this world.
SCP-682 did everything it could to shut out
the voice, even as Jerry took off and flew
deeper into the crimson forests of Level 14.
Without even realizing, 682 had grown a pair
of blue wings of its own. It followed Jerry
through the trees and then higher towards the
starry sky. One thought cut all the negativity
that had been swirling through SCP-682’s mind.
It doesn’t matter if I don’t belong
anywhere else. Jerry is all I need.
A light shone down from above, and suddenly it
was as if Level 14 itself was rejecting SCP-682.
While the reptile was focused on Jerry, a piece
of the sky seemed to glitch, and then - as if
it were a solid piece of machinery - it
fell down towards the red grass below.
Behind the fallen chunk of sky was a metallic
hallway, not unlike some of those back at The
Foundation. Jerry flew through the opening, and
SCP-682 followed with its own macaw-like feathered
wings. A shift in gravity, much like the event
on level 7 occurred, and 682 soon found itself
standing inside of the long silvery corridor,
having come through a hole in the ceiling.
Goodbye, Level 14.
Hello, Level 15 - The Futuristic Hallways.
Aww yeah! The Future Rules!
Here we are in the future, and it's right! It
was certainly a lot less of a personal nightmare
to SCP-682. Jerry had clearly flown ahead, but
682 knew somewhere deep down that it wouldn’t
have made it here without him. If the reptile
had any respect for the concept of fairness,
it’d probably consider the debt for Jerry fleeing
in Level 10 to be repaid. But its empathy wasn’t
quite so sophisticated that it could
weigh favors like that so it soldiered on,
looking to catch up with Jerry for no
particular reason. At least as far as it knew.
The hallways were definitely manmade in
appearance, but from a time so technologically
advanced that even The Foundation couldn’t
dream of it. The best part about level 15
was that it was filled with what appeared to
be human remains. Most of these corpses were
marked with knife and gunshot wounds, perhaps the
result of some kind of mass-slaughter. Either way,
it was clear that all of these
humans had been dead for a long time.
The only good human is a dead
human. SCP-682 mused to itself.
It seemed that the future did in fact
kinda rule, because from 682’s perspective
Level 15 was populated entirely by “good
humans.” There was still no sign of Jerry,
but there were also no annoying entities to
waste the reptile’s time. Compared to Level 14,
the futuristic hallways were the real paradise.
While it was as far away as ever from
feeling any kind of authentic contentment,
SCP-682 decided that this place was acceptable.
No life. No Foundation. I’m
starting to like it here.
Now go check out “Could SCP-682 be Contained
in the Backrooms?” and “SCP-682 Slaughters
Through the Backrooms” for more of the Hard
to Destroy Lizard wrecking this liminal hell!